bonjour à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation d'abord que pouvez vous
nous dire quel est votre lecture de la
situation en irak
la situation est compliquée complètement
maintenant c'est classe politique
incapable
elle est à population révoltée qui
n'acceptent pas maintenant quelle que
soit n'est pas de conte premier poteau
il faut changer d'avoir le moment il
faut changer le parlement il faut qu'ils
y aillent nouvelle loi électorale
il faut aller à oscillation gouvernement
ne coûte rien et toujours sur
l'ingérence de l'iran donc n'a pas
vraiment la solution
pour le moment on verra ce que ça va
être la situation dans les jours qui
viennent dit que le contexte aux
régionales jouent un rôle sur la
situation aujourd'hui en irak
on pèse lourd ça veut dire beaucoup
d'affluence pour l'iran et les
etats-unis aussi l'arabie saoudite et or
comptent pays voisins de l'irak mais pas
vraiment actuellement sur la population
il n'y a pas vraiment ça veut dire une
influence directe de ce pays les gens
veulent avoir une nationalité irakienne
et vie normale comme les autres le vit
aussi avec dignité et gmp très riche
mais aussi la population très pauvre la
foi alors 400 morts depuis le début de
ce mouvement de contestation
dans ce contexte là on a du mal à
comprendre pourquoi le gouvernement
campe sur ses positions
saveurs les gouvernements il n'est pas
vraiment libre à la soul influence de
ces un gouvernement pro iranien en tout
cas donc calé à des changement est
radical
le problème actuellement secoue la
classe politique et le pays voisins même
les états unis n'ont pas un plan b ce
qu'on peut appeler blanc dit jusqu'à
maintenant il n'ya pas solution tout le
monde attend de la situation
l'appelation aux hommes
las de cette situation donc je pense que
les à un changement dans les jours qui
viennent
peut-être le premier ministre va être
nommé rapidement par le président
jusqu'à maintenant elle est à deux trois
candidats mais c'est pas qui va être
vraiment là le prochain premier ministre
ils les irakiens jusqu'où sont ils prêts
à aller
apparemment c'est une révolution
populaire le je n'accepte pas un
changement artificiel je cherche pas à
une compromis et je crois le pro
iraniens vont vont perdre beaucoup à ce
que la population n'accepte pas surtout
c'est une population de ce qu'on appelle
le chili la grande ville chiite
bagdad bassorah et aussi la nasa ya
surtout et donc je crois pas qu'il y ait
un grand prix mais surtout la classe
politique est complètement aveugle si on
veut dire l'avenir de l'irak
comment est ce que vous voyez cet avenir
dit toujours la plus ancienne et
d'allemand depuis donc elle a vu
beaucoup de problèmes dans l'histoire de
trois siècles sous l'occupation ottomane
pas un mais le pays est toujours là
c'est une seul grand pays un grand
peuple et je pense on a toujours un
touriste mais de façon c'est très
difficile et très compliqué alors tout à
l'heure vous avez fait allusion
justement à l' influence du contexte
régional vous parlez des états unis
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui
sur l' influence américaine en irak les
américains ont tort de laisser le pays
entre les mains des iraniens se dire
surtout pendant la période de obama
l'irak était pratiquement laissé pourrir
un fait
bien que le deuxième a qu'un sont
arrivés en 2003 pour occuper le pays
échangent à l'origine trop misé avoir un
gant noir démocratique normal elle
finalement alors vraiment fait de firmin
donc je pense que les etats unis a perdu
beaucoup d influence en irak nouvelle
force militaire pour faire pour toi elle
pour attaquer et c
mais sur le plan populaire l'a pas vrai
et c'est la même chose pour l'iran il ya
deux groupes de mélie chea pro-iranien
très armée très fort mais la même temps
ce sont pas populaires sont considérés
comme imposé par les rangs sur la
population irakienne
merci beaucoup m aïdaoui je rappelle que
vous êtes à pau est un ancien conseiller
politique principal de l'onu en irak
merci pour votre éclairage